oh my neck yeah do that like hey really
good yes let's do it
everybody I'm John Luke with all isandro
we're at QuakeCon 2018 we saw the
fallout 76 panel and I can't say I feel
a little bit better about the game now
more confident in what that game is
typically like QA panels they don't feel
like they don't say that much but they
actually kind of answer a lot of
people's questions about the scale yeah
I actually feel a lot better about the
game - one thing we got was a more
detailed look at the character
progression system which is you know
something that's been on everyone's
minds like since they revealed this game
Matt oh sure how do you do that in a
game that's like got PvP yeah I mean
like you know it's online and like
everyone sort of together and like you
know they had to come up with a system
that's balanced that works for everyone
so first off the special system makes it
come back it's on a Fallout game without
the special system and so what they did
was that you every time you level up you
would place a point in one of the
several categories like strength
perception endurance and what have you
and so once you put a point in one of
those categories that means you get to
use one of the part cars that you have
and you're your inventory so if you have
like four points in strength let's say
that means you can ideally you know put
like a level three perk card the end one
the level one perk card adding up to
four strengths right so the perk cards
that are increasingly more powerful that
you can't use until you level up
appropriately right so every few levels
you'll actually get access to a perk
card pack and up in that pack comes like
a random set of like a perks or / cards
and uh and bubble gum and bubble gum
yeah it comes with a joke and the gum
actually you know keeps you from going
hungry just for a little bit but yeah
that's a nice touch although I have to
wonder you got card packs
you know the random cards in them that
feels very primed for microtransaction
yes you me and everyone in that room
like I that panel was thinking the same
thing
in all said good but capital yeah I mean
plus it's gonna be on Bethesda net as
well it's not my team anymore so kind of
lines up but you know of course they
haven't said anything about it
no microtransactions of course but yeah
yeah I'm really interested in seeing how
players will be able to sort of develop
their characters through this new
character create a progression system
exactly cuz you using the perk cards you
can kind of change and swap Emma flies
you know theoretically make you know
whatever character you want you can't do
a jack-of-all-trades character it was
sort of a big point they're making and
the idea is that you party that you're
kind of substituting roles for you know
this person can be like a support
character and this person can be more of
like a sniper but it's interesting that
they let you just kind of like swap on
the fly yeah then you're actually able
to move any / cards around at any time
so if you you know put a lot of points
and strengthen you start developing
stuff in like endurance or even like
luck
that means further along like in your
progression you know you'll be able to
adjust things again the strength you
know category right yeah and they did
say that they're they're working to make
sure that it's not overpowering right
for so I think there is a there is a cap
at fifty you stop getting points but you
still get more cards at that point that
you can definitely and one thing I'm
really interested in seeing is how high
level of characters will end up which of
course will tie into like you know sort
of PvP aspect exactly yeah so they were
there talked a lot about the PDP and how
that's gonna work
it was interesting they're saying it is
possible for like a level like a
beginner level player to actually kill
like a high level player you know like
smart enough and there's gonna be like
an increase payout which is in this
thing but they're kind of big thing they
talked about was griefing yeah that is
gonna play into the game that's one
thing a lot of people were really
concerned about when
they announced this game and showed off
more of it at e3 like a you know
griefing has been there like it really
it's been like a really complicated
thing to deal with
sure in a lot of games yeah I I'm glad
they're not shying away from briefing
entirely like they've actually kind of
embraced it there's racing in a nice
sort of respect that like I think
they're really trying to like take that
idea of like well griefing develops
interesting nori stories and narratives
for a player but they want to make sure
that briefing isn't abused so if you
attack a player you only do a minimal
amount of damage until that player then
like engages back and it becomes a
proper duel and then even if that other
player does keep attacking you over and
over and kills you they become like a
wanted murderer yeah and then their name
just like appears on the map they appear
as a Red Storm we didn't star in the map
and everybody knows where they are
and you have to go hunt them down and
kill them if you kill them the bounty
you get actually goes from that players
cap so it's a really clever way it's a
clever way of getting around it I mean I
think I like how Todd mention that it's
a it's a its content yeah yeah grief and
griefing can lead to actual future
content and like your your your play
session right and we did this we have
this idea like let's let's turn it like
like let's make them interesting content
and it is when this happens when anybody
murders somebody when we're playing in
the office everyone sees in the map and
it is like they're it's awesome so I
think it's that's a good way of
incentivizing
players to not want to grieve at least
on that level and but at the same time I
can see a high level player making that
conscious decision I'm going to become
this murder
the other like really commit to it yeah
you're gonna you got to commit to it and
that makes the role-playing interesting
and then conversely you can have players
who's like I'm gonna roleplay like an
avenging spirit who will you know kill
these people who have been
you know like the equivalent of the like
mystery stranger
yeah which is a really cool idea you can
roleplay as the mysterious stranger
exactly but of course if you want to
avoid like any of that you can always
walk players as well yeah you can block
players so they can't see you on the map
the games got voice chat which I'm
excited for but also you can meet people
which is yeah that's that's always
important especially in a game like that
totally because the big thing that I
feel like it's still concerning for a
lot of people is just that the game
doesn't have any NPCs in it at all it's
all players right that's one thing I'm
still a little concerned about because
I'm I always enjoy that sort of like
solitaire aspect to fallout right but I
mean I enjoy like you know being able to
occasionally wonder in the towns and
like meet other characters tandem and as
I said there in the panel like the other
players online are the characters of a
world in sure and I do I trust you know
weed smoke 420 to be like an interesting
character for me probably not at launch
but I am exciting a good guy you never
know it could be great who knows but I'm
excited I feel like this game is going
to get a lot better in like the months
after launch when the when kind of like
the majority of people leave the game
and then you got that really hardcore
fanbase of sticks around I think that's
where the game is really gonna thrive
you're gonna get people who are into
roleplay oh you're gonna get people who
like genuinely like care about like
making it interesting and not just being
an [ __ ] for the sake of being an
[ __ ] yeah and I think that's probably
when the game's gonna be at it's like
most fun yeah definitely and we might be
getting our head over ourselves here
because we haven't seen the full game
yet right it's hard to say but it is
gonna be interesting to see where the
game can grow like beyond like though
maybe West Virginia a map
right yeah they've kind of said that
they have a roadmap for what they're
doing but that it is they're gonna kind
of adjust it based on how what the
things that players are liking and kind
of gravitating towards in the game so I
imagine the lad new quests and stuff
like that but I think a lot of it is
gonna be that like player interaction
tools right you know kind of PvP almost
like a merciless in like element yeah
what I'm hoping for
there is this great anecdote where
they're talking about the this guy grows
like a tuba he built his camp and he's
sitting in the middle of a road playing
a tuba huh and he's on his platform and
he had built all these turrets in the
foliage you can't see and everyone just
like this guy in tuba like and then the
Curt just like killing everybody zarkan
the whole time awesome that's great
that's so fall out to like it's very
fall out and like the idea of like you
can make your own whacking you fall out
after that's interacting with other
people I think how does like a ton of
potential it's just like is the internet
actually gonna play nice we'll see a lot
of weird hijinks like in publications
like the first few months but um I am
very interested in seeing like you know
for one game my hands on it definitely
yeah definitely the beta is coming out
in October
mm-hmm and that's everyone's first shot
at the game so yeah
yeah I mean even though it's a big
change for what from what we've seen in
previous Fallout games it is actually
pulling a lot of like influences from
the earlier ones as well like yeah
compared to like you know fallout 4
which was I guess the biggest change the
series have had at that point
fallout 76 is actually bringing back up
mutations like which is another aspect
of character for sure like mutations and
just I think I think they're really
gonna leave storytelling a lot more
that's one because there's no DC
characters second PC can't use but they
got this massive map that's gonna have
you know all this like cool buildings
and I think they're gonna have loss of
that kind of stuff it's several times
bigger than the Commonwealth as well
right fallout fourth so yeah I think at
this point I just feel like I have a
better under
what this game is and I think for those
players who are maybe looking for a more
solitary experience this I don't think
this game is gonna be for that probably
not but I feel like at least we know now
they are they said they're gonna do
stuff like private servers at some point
they're working on it
I doubt it's gonna be a launch they also
have been working on mods which I think
it's really cool like there's a lot of
potential there I'm interested in CVP
yeah I'm very interested in seeing how
that's implemented especially since this
is an online game and you know while
other players sort of see like you know
how like other characters like outfit a
little modded content or yeah so it
sounds like they have interesting
systems in player for you to interact
with other players and you just interact
with your friends I feel like I'm gonna
have a really good time but a couple of
friends playing this game definitely
much yeah obviously this is a big change
for a fallout but I feel you know this
change could be a good you know a good
thing you know it could be a nice sort
of switch from you know what people
usually expect from I I think defense
does kind of get into stretch its
creative muscles and try something
different and you know I mean they've
they've said before that this doesn't
mean they're not ever doing
single-player again like I feel very
confident that an eventual fall 5 will
be a more traditional of course
experience that we all all expect as a
hand-picked resident of both 76 it is
your duty to carefully review your
vault-tec provided films yearly to fully
prepare for the day where
you will emerge alright so I think we
both feel a little bit better now about
falling 76 now that we have a more
concrete idea of what the game is we
still haven't seen much gameplay I'd
want to see more of that I want to know
what's up with the beta yeah we know
it's coming out in October but when in
October when in October how much of the
game is in there but you know Dan's
coming out soon in November remember and
for everything to fall out 76 stay tuned
to games